voilà jackson bonjour c'est très gentil
et banjo avec nous ce soir vous parler
français c'est extraordinaire oui vous
savez vous êtes vraiment star en asie
est ce que vous saviez que vous étiez
comme ça très connu dans tout l'est en
france chez les jeunes surtout
maintenant je laissais ce matin il y
avait un jeune qui est venu me voir qui
m'a appelé karaté kid taekwondo kid
donc je me rends compte je suis très
content toutes ces années de travail et
tout ses films d'action sans trop de
violences car les jeunes me préoccupe
beaucoup et il me regarde beaucoup au
cinéma
qu'est ce qui plaît aux aux jeunes
d'après vous dans vos films vous dites
y'a pas de violence il n'y a pas de ya
pas de sens tout à fait dans mes films
j'utilise pas un pistolet pour faire
sortir le sens beaucoup de combats
violents n'ont jamais beaucoup de
mouvements gaïdar le dicton le public
toile et il tombe et une autre qui
remonte mais pas de sang rien et moi je
veux que je vais fléchier comment je
peux en fait d'être débarrassé des armes
à feu ils disaient mais quelle que soit
la façon dont je le fais à la fin c'est
ce qu'ils avaient plusieurs comptes en
sait pas faire ça c'est trop violent ça
pourtant vous y allez donc en à votre
fils quand même hein c'est assez fort ce
que vous faites
mais le plus important c'est l'action et
l'humour tous ensemble que les enfants
voient ça taekwondo comme cela les motos
sont l immeuble à l'autre mais à la fin
je leur montrer qu en fait oui il
m'arrive de me placer message le plus
important ce n est pas faire comme moi
et il ya une violence qui bonne violence
qu'il est en fait l'action c'est
peut-être violent mais c'est jack
reacher comparé à la vivent seuls en
amérique quand on va au cinéma américain
c'est juste un tout petit peu que je
fais là justement vous allez tourner aux
états unis vous tournez avec des
américains
passion que ça change la facture du film
qu'il est mieux travailler entre
guillemets qu'un film que vous faisiez
auparavant à hiesse en amérique elles
ont un autre système
quand je fais un film chez sur le
plateau je n'ai pas une loge sur
roulettes
j'ai pas je suis content assistant en
place et tout le monde nous fait doit
faire tout je fais tout je fais mon
maquillage je vais chercher de l'eau en
numérique un énorme joue aussi bien
humainement
des gars comme fou tu fais je suis
toujours entouré et je ne vais pas tout
ce que je voudrais passer de la loge bon
enfin tâche et doublure rêve ça va vous
changer de l'école d'opéra chinois de
hong kong quand même c'était pas tout à
fait le même traitement l'a20 ya faute
ou les diplômes tout à fait différent
totalement différent cette école de
quartier chic je suis contente j'ai
beaucoup appris en serez à 5 heures du
matin on s'entraînait 19 heures par jour
chanter l acrobatie couvert et j'ai pu
utiliser toutes les techniques dans mes
films de chant qu'est ce que vous vous
ne vous faites jamais doublé dans les
films c'est parce que j'ai l'impression
que si vous vous d'où vous vous faisiez
doublé ce serait tricher avec le public
yes quand je réalise une cascade
il s'agit de l'action cinéma d'action
sauter dans l'immeuble un autre part d
une fois que je fais moi même mais si
j'étais vous je sais pas le faire donc
j'utilise double pilotes par exemple je
me suis fait quelques années j'avais
chez pages quand mon père michel un
conduit au top j'ai été doublé pour
conduire la voiture
l'acrobatie sauter tout ça je fais tout
ça et est-ce que vous avez compté s'est
étalé leurs questions mais ce que vous
avez compter le nombre de fois vous êtes
pris des claques ou des coudes en vo
dans vos films on aux abymes making of
people qui c'est qui a fait 31 25 ans je
fais des cascades tout a été cassé
un choix a sonné et paul l'étoile tous
les doigts de la main
les gens les quote j'ai fait mal
d'autant que le public regarde mes films
gens qui sont contents qu'elle vous êtes
cassé par vous fait ça par plaisir quand
même
l'histoire vous fait ça par plaisir
quand même haïti ce loft mais pas ce que
je veux c'est rendre les enfants parce
que mon public
le monde entier comptait voir mes films
je ferai tout ce que je peux
merci beaucoup en tout cas merci vous et
bonne chance pour votre fils mercredi
qui sort en france sur les sur les
écrans merci encore oui